en este vídeo vamos a practicar
estimando la multiplicación aquí tenemos
un signo de interrogación y luego este
signo de igual ondulado y puedes ver
este signo de igual ondulado como cuál
es el resultado aproximado de esto no
tiene que ser exactamente igual entonces
cuál es el resultado aproximado de
multiplicar 58 por 6 cuál de estas
opciones elegirías pausa el vídeo y
trata de resolverlo así que una vez más
no tenemos que obtener esto exactamente
sólo necesitamos estimar a que es igual
58 por 6 y la forma en que lo abordaría
es puede reescribir 58 como un número
que sea fácil de multiplicar por 6 o
fácil de multiplicar en general y es
fácil pensar que 58 está muy cerca de 60
de modo que si decimos que esto es
cercano a 60 si solo lo estimamos bueno
cuánto sería 60 por 6 bueno 60 por 6 es
lo mismo que dejen de escribirlo de esta
manera puedes ver 60 por 6 cómo
por 10 por 6 y también puedes verlo como
6 por 6 por 10 y cuánto es 6 por 6 es
igual a 36 y luego 36 por 10 es igual a
360 así que voy a elegir esta opción
fíjense que estas otras opciones no se
acercan a esto por lo que nos sentimos
muy bien con nuestra estimación hagamos
otro ejemplo aquí se nos pregunta cuánto
estrés por 2.890 cuál es el resultado
aproximado como estimar y asestó pausa
el vídeo y trata de resolverlo muy bien
entonces no es fácil multiplicar dos mil
890 en nuestras mentes pero puedo decir
que es algo como 3000 así que voy a
decir que esto es aproximadamente igual
a 3 por 3000 ahora cuánto es 3 x 3 es
igual a 9 entonces cuánto estrés por
3000 es igual a 9000 así que la opción
es esta que tenemos aquí si lo que acabo
de hacer fue un poco confuso puedes ver
tres por tres mil como tres por tres por
mil esa parte de aquí es igual a tres
mil tres por tres es igual a nueve y así
tienes 9000 hagamos un ejemplo más
este tiene números bastante grandes
entonces si tuvieras que estimar 5.111
por 9 cuál de estos elegirías pausa el
vídeo y trata de responder muy bien yo
vería esto como 5000 por 9 de ese modo
cinco mil por nueve es lo mismo que
cinco por mil por nueve que es lo mismo
que 5 por 9 por mil 5 por 9 es igual a
45 por lo que esto es igual a 45.000 que
es esta opción justo aquí